Die pest ist
Die krankheit dem mittelalter in europa millionen menschen getötet hat breitet sich in madagaskar in afrika aus alle paar tage
Verdoppeln sich die fallzahlen, was nichts gutes ahnen lässt
Wie glücklich ist die krankheit und wie bedrohlich ist sie für uns jetzt sind links und sein verwischen herzlich willkommen
Es gibt bereits mehr als 100 tote und mehr als 1000 infizierte, also zehn prozent
Der erkrankten sterben eine extrem gefährliche krankheit mit einer unheimlichen geschichte, der schwarze tod im mittelalter
grassierte die pest
Unheimlich und tötete 25 millionen menschen
Es war ein drittel aller europäer eine der schlimmsten epidemien überhaupt immer wieder gab es sie und erst
1894 wurde der erreger vom französischen arzt alexandre llosa
Identifiziert und der übertragungsweg geklärt hier in europa taucht
Die pest seitdem kaum noch auf aber immerhin in 21 anderen ländern vereinzelt sogar in den usa in madagaskar ist
Die pest seit
2008 wieder vermehrt aufgetreten und hat jetzt zu der schlimmsten epidemie geführt dort
Wie so oft fängt alles mit einem einzelnen fall an der durch ganz bestimmte umstände zu einer massenweisen verbreitung
Führt bei ebola war es eine riesige beerdigung bei der alle gäste den leichnam an fasten und sich dann wieder in alle himmelsrichtungen
Zerstreut und die solche so verbreiteten beim aktuellen test ausbruch in madagaskar war es ein
Busreisende der alle mitreisenden in einem bus ansteckten so zur verbreitung bei druck, wie bei ebola ist es im nachhinein
unmöglich, die infizierten auszumachen und zu isolieren die seuche verbreitet sich wie in europa im mittelalter kamen auch in
Madagaskar, die solche mit schiffen aus asien, das bakterium yersinia pestis
Fragen ratten in sich sie werden von flöhen gebissen, die das bakterium dann über flohbisse auf andere wirte eben auch den menschen
Übertragen dabei kann, die pest auf drei arten ausbrechen bei der pest
Blutvergiftung da gehen die bakterien
Die bleiben im blut und töten innerhalb von ein paar tagen bei der beulenpest, sie liehen sie sich in den lymphknoten an die tennisballgroßen
Schwellen und wenn diese platzen dann verbreiten sich die bakterien und stecken andere menschen an am ansteckendsten
Ist die lungenpest?
Hier sind die bakterien in der lunge und werden durch die atemluft zb beim pusten vor allen dingen verbreitet genau der fall
Der die epidemie über den mitreisenden im bus verbreitet hat, jetzt ist dieser ausbruch zum größten ausbruch
Der pest in afrika geworden und ein ende ist nicht abzusehen
die menschen schlafen hier und das ist ein
Schwieriger und stand zum teil in hütten auf dem boden
Krankenhäuser und ärzte, die sind weit entfernt ideale voraussetzung für die ausbreitung
Der epidemie hat sich hier jemand infiziert hat er einige tage zeit die erreger zu verbreiten die langen
Reaktionszeiten am jetzt dazu geführt, dass der erreger die hauptstadt antananarivo
Und überhaupt städte erreicht hat in denen er sich viel viel schneller
Ausbreiten und deutlich mehr menschen infizieren kann, die regierung hat jetzt versammlungen und kundgebungen
Verboten doch das scheint nicht viel zu nützen
Millionen menschen drängen sich in den städten in den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln und tragen
Die solche soweit im moment sieht es nicht so aus, dass die solche
Eingegrenzt werden könnte dabei gäbe es ganz gute
Behandlungsmethoden gegen die pest zwar sind, die bakterien inzwischen gegen einige antibiotika resistent
Wie inzwischen in madagaskar festgestellt wurde, aber es gibt noch genügend antibiotika
Die wenn er kein video zum thema noch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt, dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge vergessen sich den
Auf die glocke damit auch wirklich benachrichtigt werden, wenn ein neues video kommt und hier geht es weiter mit droht eine pandemie
Dann geht es um das extrem gefährliche virus sich moment verbreitet ansonsten. Bis dann